Булочки, батони, тістечка і рогалики.
би вже незабаром можуть стати в рази дорожчими.
Або ж узагалі - зникнуть з полиць.
Цей хлібокомбінат за день виробляє приблизно 100 тонн хліба.
Однак тепер, через нові тарифи на газ, опалювати завод стало у понад десятеро дорожче.
Оплата газу за один робочий день у січні обійдеться компанії в понад 500 000 гривень ß
замість 30 000 минулими місяцями.
Якщо ми на початку брали газ по ціні від 5 до 6 тисяч гривень за тисячу кубометрів,
то вчорашня пропозиція на січень була 73 тисячі.
Для нас це просто катастрофа.
Оскільки газ має досить суттєву вагу в собівартості і не може не позначитися на ціні хліба.
За 2021 рік ціна на хліб зросла в середньому на 16%.
Головною причиною виробники називають стрімке зростання майже всіх складових собівартості хліба.
Окрім газу, зросла й вартість електроенергії - вдвічі.
Ціна борошна підвищилася на 40%.
Представник галузі Олександр Тараненко каже, що його підприємство вимушене було підняти ціну на хліб на 20%.
Хоча собівартість зросла на 50%.
За таких умов стримувати подорожчання хлібобулочних виробів довго не вдасться.
Таким чином з останніми цінами на газ ми входимо глибоко у збитки. І не піднімати ціни ми просто не можемо.
Якщо ми цього не зробимо, нам не буде чим розраховуватися за сировину.
Тому що за газ ми змушені заплатити, зрозуміло, інакше не буде на чому випікати.
Податки ми змушені заплатити, залишається сировина і заробітна плата.
Таке підвищення цін уже відчули українські споживачі.
Я ще пам'ятаю старі ціни, то для мене це взагалі космос.
Ми багато не беремо, ми беремо потрошку. Бо занадто дорого зараз.
Куди дінешся - скільки б він не подорожчав, усе одно будемо платити.
Забирають у нас останні копійки. Тільки й вистачає, що заплатити за комуналку і продукти.
За 30 гривень, може, й будемо брати, але не дорожче.
А якщо дорожче, то будемо без хліба, це не смертельно.
Я вважаю, що хліб недешево має коштувати, бо це праця.
Але з іншого боку, деякі люди і цього не можуть собі дозволити.
Окрім комунальних тарифів, також зросла ціна на основну сировину для хлібозаводів - зерно.
Ціна, яку платять українські виробники за українське зерно, - європейська.
Тобто та, яку українські аграрії встановлюють, щоб продавати своє зерно на експорт.
А отже, коли на світовому ринку зростає ціна зерна, вона зростає і для українських пекарів.
Експортна ціна  на українську пшеницю, починаючи зі старту маркетингового року,
тобто з першого липня 2021, станом на кінець грудня зросла приблизно на 90 доларів.
Тобто 320 доларів за тонну зерна.
Зі старту сезону, зі жнив. 90 доларів - це багато. Ціна зараз є доволі значною.
Це відчувається скрізь у світі, продукти скрізь дорожчають, і хліб також.
На ціну зерна впливає багато факторів.
Зокрема погодні негаразди - такі як посухи чи надмірні дощі.
Інфляційні процеси, які відбуваються у всьому світі через пандемію.
А також зростання цін на нафту та мінеральні добрива.
За словами експертки з питань агарного сектора, українським фермерам не принципово,
кому продавати зерно - за кордон чи всередині країни.
Їм важливо отримувати ринкову ціну за свій товар.
Український фермер дуже неохоче пристає на будь-які пропозиції зі зниження вартості зерна.
На сьогодні, якщо він має якісне зерно, він буде сидіти на тому зерні і чекати кращої ціни.
І ви не змусите продати його дешевше.
В Україні лунали пропозиції, що слід регулювати ціни на зерно, обмеживши для аграріїв експорт.
Однак у Всеукраїнській аграрній раді зазначають, що це суперечитиме ринковій економіці.
Чому всередині країни аграрію, який витратив велику кількість коштів для того,
щоб його виростити, не може продавати своє зерно за ринковою ціною,
а через певні заяви його хочуть змусити, щоб він усередині країни він продавав дешевше, щоб обмежити експорт.
Це явно не ринкова економіка, це явно не ті правила, за які ми вболівали.
Хочете купувати якісну сировину - контрактуйте, платіть за неї ринкову ціну.
На думку експерта, одним із способів призупинити зростання цін -
це зменшити ставку ПДВ на соціально значущі продукти харчування, зокрема на хліб.
Тому що коли ми виходимо з вами в магазин, і на полицях магазину ми бачимо одну чи іншу ціну,
то автоматично ми сплачуємо близько 20% ПДВ, яке рахується державі.
У світі на соціально значущі продукти ПДВ складає лише 5-10%.
У нас це 20%, що фактично прирівнюється до всіх промислових великих товарів.
Це несправедливо, і бідне соціально-незахищене населення не має можливості купити собі ту чи іншу продукцію.
У Всеукраїнській асоціації пекарів вважають, що ситуацію треба було рятувати раніше.
Тепер єдине, що може зробити держава, - це дати компаніям пільги на газ.
Наприкінці року у Міненерго оголосили, що для виробників соціально важливих продуктів
обмежать націнки на видобутий в Україні газ на рівні 25%.
Олександр Тараненко вважає, що це справді може допомогти пекарям
впоратися бодай з комунальними платежами.
Однак зростання ціни на хліб це все одно не стримає - лише дещо пригальмує.
За прогнозами експертів, хліб для українців дорожчатиме на один-півтора відсотка щомісяця,
а деякі підприємства, які не зможуть працювати за новими енергетичними тарифами,
навіть вимушені будуть частково призупинити виробництво.
Затримки по заробітній платі вже виникають.
Багато підприємств зараз тільки виплачують зарплати за листопад.
І якщо ми заплатимо за січневий газ за такими цінами, то ми не зможемо заплатити ні зарплати, ні за борошно.
Відповідно нам не дадуть борошно, і не буде з чого випікати хліб.
За даними Держстату, найбільше українці витрачають саме на продукти харчування - більше 40 відсотків доходів.
Для порівняння - німці витрачають на харчі лише 15 з половиною відсотків доходів.
І прогнози, на жаль, не втішні: зростання цін на продовольчі товари у світі
ще більше позначиться на сімейних бюджетах українців.